hey guys wait how's it going Nick Regine
this is Jenna my sister hello
she's been here for quite a lot of my
youtube videos I started making YouTube
videos back in 2006 when did you start
2010 January sounds about right
I forced her to make a channel so today
we're going to react to some of my old
YouTube videos are you ready no because
I know I'm going to be in some of these
as well and it's gonna be equally
horrifying for me okay you ready for
this huh okay here we go
the iPhone bill video August 13 2007
this is not your first video like videos
[Music]
video so many times that I'm not used by
it at all and are you face yourself
looking at those eyebrows wait a minute
what about what it's in necklace why are
you wearing a shimmery tank I weren't I
think that might actually have been
brianne's
tank top and looks like it's from like
Express a business address yeah what are
you doing there I'm flipping through all
of the pages of my phone bill which was
like 300 some pages and the crazy part
about it they itemized every single text
message that I had sent back then you
guys okay if I look closely I can read
your text messages no it didn't give you
the text text but it did give you like
two phone numbers and people that you
were texting that's in Danny Angeles
video which I did like a year later why
do you look like that that's my question
I look like your hair and eyebrows have
come very long here this is Halloween
this is a year after the iPhone build
video and I'm kind of just revisiting
the place that I went and made the video
okay so you've made it looks like you
may have worn it keep them out of
Tiffany's my life no it's not it's
American Idol diner from temperature
scale actually okay so you hop green a
little bit there I'm wearing Lululemon
this is when my personal me women
jackets I ever bought I'm so close to
the camera I don't know oh I'm making
fun of myself
- hi my friend Lee outlet how do you
think looks like they did an extra paint
job okay on my wall this little but what
a sidebar
this was whenever the YouTube went to
the 16 by 9 aspect ratio and I didn't
have a camera to shot yet Oh only a
glass and what is that no snow cover up
the eyebrows oh look at those eyebrows
so what is like you to initially I did I
felt my one year not really and you
thought that was really going okay so
you were 10 years ago 2008 nine years
ago I've ever seen a really high
watchers yeah you were really wearing
hangs up phone remember a tank top I'm
gonna look boy I even go tanning a lot
yeah you would look like look how panel
yeah it's your night you're so young why
getting old
come on now I'm real good yes I've seen
this video yes oh me oh yeah I only has
half a million views I mean you know I
guess people weren't that into it okay
turning it down because this is copy
written music this is from The Boondock
Saints soundtrack which is one of my
favorite movies Wow well not like just
say where's the rest you don't really
like a prompt jacket to your 20s which
is awesome sick sorry - wow look at me
look at me so young and Bart maverick
tanky oh I was over just already gonna
drive Oh turns car now I'm eatin me Oh
feel now I must say times has been
generous to you what is on me look man
you look nice now do you think I look
bad you don't look bad you just um check
out this one I used to be as an apple
tours a lot this is to 2009 kyoool why I
was a damn campus tour I don't like your
having you there
hey long time
I love it but I don't remember where we
were suckle when I'm wearing my hair at
all it was very long what have I gotten
my sweater on and a tank top
let's shoot them away rate 5 stars
oh my god another one brain 5 star yeah
okay when you're resist 2009 l9 so eight
years ago I was 19 oh look a cute little
girl it is Phoebe okay well that's
enough of that teen years old let's
flash forward to minute 2010 trance on
your head I already know I don't want to
be here I want to run out on my head
brush my hair brush my hair I want to
have a voice why do i why is that my
voice I don't know I thought it fit with
the song but it doesn't make sense it
doesn't make any sense why my goods to
Shaco coloring everything looks for
widows good this is seven years ago we
didn't have watching it now you're right
I don't want to but the thing is I
remember us thinking what's this going
to be incredible image so great we are
right in the lyrics out but then somehow
you gave me that voice well so I've
always loved technology and I used to do
well like an SD a 15-member those
cameras what are you it's when I rinse
my hair I basically just bought
everything at Urban Outfitters sources
from urban knocked in our bones but I'll
tell you the fashion in urban Elle I'm
not really changed a lot sure which do
you like my outfit I do not like my
outfit
no I absolutely do not like your outfit
more jewelry that's just questionable
questionable jewelry questionable
pushable brow you like my arms please
bow we doesn't like what the Roseman
yeah before and michael buckley for the
first time you met you you had socks on
your arm yes this was that what am i do
i do it with a cold we relocated I was
you know in LA I was in LA here okay I'm
pretty up
I laughed I've been the only person in
Los Angeles to ever wear and warmer know
the cool thing everyone was doing it
every summer brush my hair brush my hair
brush my hair
oh gosh RLC one last one I've never seen
what what is Jeff Bezos CEO of Amazon
South by Southwest March 9 2008 I never
exactly yes what is your favorite tree
very consistently you will be amazon.com
probably bread pudding right out there
now that you posted a Swami to second
video ok how many assume was way
different back in the day if you imagine
today posting a 22 second clip on
YouTube and the 22 second people would
be like what youtube georgeous crisis
tour in two seconds and I'm left as well
within the video but there's nowhere
else to even post the type of content
like there was nowhere to go when we
have 23,000 views
why thank you so much for watching I
will put links to those videos in the
description below and stay tuned for our
part 2 because there's so many videos
among looking at hair and Peter super
embarrassing ones of Jenna oh my god the
hair sphere what if those a lot in the
network you had the eyebrows I had
something I had a lot more things make
sure you guys go check out Jenna's
channel and stay tuned for part two
because let me tell you what I've got
some fun things lined up you know what I
didn't do huh report everyone freeze
[Music]